From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Good morning.
This is Emilye Crosby with Mr. Reggie Robinson on December 11, 2015 at the Library of Congress with the Civil Rights History Project,
and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and John Bishop with also with us.
Good morning, Mr. Robinson.
Good morning, y'all.
It's nice to have you here, and to glad you're here to participate in the project.
Well, it's been an uphill struggle, as you know.
But they come a time.
They come a time.
Can you tell us when and where you were born and about your family?
Well, I was born in Baltimore, Maryland, October 2, 1939, to Leroy and Leo Vesta, L-E-O-V-E-S-T-E-R Robinson.
My mother's maiden name was Jenkins.
I had one brother.
I have one brother still living, who was the oldest.
His name was Leroy.
I had a sister named Lula Jean, and she was between the two of us.
It was only three siblings.
You were the baby?
I was the youngest.
What did your parents do for living?
Well, my dad worked at Bethlehem Steel for 39 years until he retired.
And he died a month after he retired.
Yes, yes.
But my mother did often on kind of housework and stuff.
She didn't really go to work until I was in the first grade.
Then they started hiring babysitters, and then I'd go to neighbor's houses.
And while she went out and did piecework or whatever to bring in a little bit more.
I went to Dunbar High School until about the tenth and a half grades.
When I discovered that I didn't quite understand what French was going to do for me.
But I was looking out the window, and I knew what I could do on the streets.
So the streets won.
And I was doing pretty well out there until the little job that I had kind of fell apart for all kinds of reasons.
And then I was frustrated because I didn't know what to do.
And it was all kinds of things to get into.
I have a cousin by the name of Josephine Thorn, who at that time was a supervisor at Social Security.
And she had went to a small business college called Cortez Peters Business College.
She convinced my father, well she convinced me first that I needed to stop doing what I was doing.
And do something.
So she convinced my father to give me another chance.
And I enrolled into Cortez Peters Business College.
Now Cortez Peters Business College was founded by a black man by the name of Cortez Peters.
It was either royal typewriter or underwear typewriter that financed him because he could type somewhere like 150 words a minute.
He advertised by having him type with an entire orchestra.
But they gave him money.
And he established three schools, one in Washington, DC, one in Baltimore, and one in Chicago.
And basically was teaching blacks how to pass government tests, teaching girls how to do shorthand.
They taught guys business law accounting, and everybody had to take typing and learn how to make and type one of them stencils.
You learn what blackout was and all of those little fancy office things.
Then in 60 when the students at Greensboro sat in and things broke loose.
There was a group that was formed in Baltimore called the Civic Interest Group.
It was the student group.
And at the same time the dean of my school, Walter Dixon, was also the City Councilman in Baltimore who had just introduced a public accommodations bill.
He kind of ordered me, I was kind of like under his thumb because he kept keep telling me my daddy didn't send me that waste money.
So he kept me under his thumb until he sent me to represent our school at the big school meetings.
When I got there I met a lot of people from all of the colleges in Maryland it looked like.
But Morgan was kind of like the head, Hancho and things.
So I got involved with the city ends around Baltimore until I got involved.
I worked my way into the group until we started moving from direct action to voter registration
where we got some money to do voter registration.
And at that time it was concentrated in one general area which was Clarence Mitchell Junior's area.
And we raised, oh I think it was about 30,000 people in a very short period of time.
So money was coming in and money had to be accounted for and we had an advisory group and everything.
So I got to be because I knew a little bit about accounting and I had worked my way into the group.
I became the treasurer of the civic interest group.
We did that and then at the June meeting in which Clarence Mitchell went to and came back and reported that the overall SNCC group was getting ready to move towards voter registration and direct action.
And also at that time Clarence's grandmother had said that the NAACP, she was president of the NAACP and she had said that she was not going to get us out of jail anymore, bail and everything.
And then Clarence had to make a decision as to whether to continue with us or go with his family.
So Clarence went with his family so that seat at SNCC from Maryland became open.
I opted to take the seat to get to go. I wanted to see the night before I left we were at a party and I got hit in the eye with a pretzel.
So before I went I had to get some ice kind of stuff done so I had this black patch over my eye.
So my orders were from Civic Interest Group because by this time everything was happening in the South.
We were getting a student voice and we were in contact with all of these guys that Chuck McDew and everything going on in Nashville and everything that's happening everywhere.
We in touch with it. So my orders were to bring the next meeting back to Baltimore and at that time, King had also stepped in because he's gotten the word that we're thinking about moving on Mississippi.
So he, him and his boys is out saying, you know, y'all can't do that, you're going to get killed and everything else though.
So I go to the SNCC meeting in Louisville, Kentucky and July of, you know, I went in June of 61.
June of 61.
When I went into the meeting, of course everybody I introduced myself and of course everybody thought I got injured in battle.
I didn't tell anybody.
So of course they moved around me very easily and we were there for the weekend.
This is, I guess, Friday night we're coming in and introducing ourselves and then by Saturday night we're having, we've been going through all through Saturday of fussing and cussing and everything.
And so we're now an am breeding house on Saturday night.
But I'm still not in with the guys because they don't know who I am and I don't know if I should say this but Clarence didn't really have a reputation of being inside the group and working.
He was known to be doing other things.
So I was trying to find out what was going on.
Anyway, I was standing on Anne Braden's porch drinking a beer by myself and this little lady walks up to me and she says, son, I know who you are.
And I says, I don't know nobody in this group and she says, where's your people from?
I told her my father was from Smithfield, Virginia and then she says, where are you from?
I said, little enough Carolina.
She says, oh, she says, what was your mom's middle name?
I said, Jenkins. She said, where was your mom's first name?
I said, Leo Vester. She said, oh, man, I know who you are.
You McKinley. I said, no, I got an uncle McKinley. She says, I know.
You exactly like him. This was Ella Baker. She said, you just like him. He works with me in New York.
And I know you're on over there because of an overdose in Baltimore.
And then the church I went to was involved in all kinds of Baptist connections and stuff.
So it was a recognized church in the Baptist conference.
So she would have known my aunt and my aunt, I can't even think of my aunt's name, but anyway.
My cousin, Overdell and her mama was very much up in the church.
And so that's why she do them and very active in the community.
So with that happening, then Miss Baker kind of smooth away.
And I became a different kind of light, I guess, to chuck in the voice.
Here what I was saying, till I won the next meeting back to Baltimore
to discuss this whole thing of going down. And in the meantime, Bob Moses has already gone to Mississippi.
It's now about August.
It's getting close to August.
We have the meeting.
And one of the first things we do is we will have this big rally in Baltimore at the Masonic Temple.
And we were going to split the proceeds with King. King was the noted speaker coming.
Everybody knew he was coming to town to be with us and convince us not to do whatever.
And we will have this big rally and everything.
So before the rally started, I convinced everybody, Albrook, that what we would do is we would open the meeting before the preacher got there.
And have our people deployed. And we would make the collection as soon as the people sat down.
So then we did that and then we split the money between SNCC and Civic Interest Group.
And so by the time Wyatt Tee Walker and the preachers got, we were going through their thing at the rally.
And Wyatt went to say, it's time for the collection.
Somebody pulled Wyatt's coat and say the collection has been done.
So I had been for Dean Dixon, Miss Baker, and then I go on and do the rest.
So you were telling me about having the collection before...
Okay, yes. So we did the collection and we split the money between Civic Interest Group and SNCC.
And of course, we're excited about what happened to Wyatt.
So then we went on with the meeting and everything.
And then it was decided that SNCC was going to do voter registration and direct action.
Somebody had to go in and be with Bob Moses and just Bob Moses.
Nobody was saying anything at the time.
So I raised my hand.
Well, I was also recognized by the time I made my report about what voter registration we did in Baltimore.
They thought I was a voter registration expert.
But all we did in Baltimore was have a soundtrack, school buses, and went around with big music.
And people came out of the house.
Got on the buses. We took them down the gate street, had big long lines.
Had the big press out there, had hot dogs. Had a big party.
People signed up thousands of people and big scene and took people back home, party in the neighborhood.
Well, they thought that I knew what I was doing.
So I was elected to go to Mississippi.
So when I left, what about the Mississippi?
Well, like I said, I mean, I had done what I could do in Baltimore.
And without going into a lot of stuff, I would have probably had a lot more trouble in Baltimore than I had in Mississippi.
Then what I did, going to Mississippi and using my energies for that, then what I would have done if I stayed in Baltimore.
My life was in just as much jeopardy.
So I chose to be productive as I thought I was being.
So then, as I'm taking off for thinking I'm going to go, I take off from Baltimore to Atlanta,
where I'm to go change trains and go to Mississippi, go to the Delta and meet Bob Moses.
When I get to Atlanta, I meet Ed King, who's our executive director at the time.
And Ed meets me at the train station and really in top hat and tails.
He had just integrated the National Symphony of Atlanta that night.
And he had been partying all night long with the people he had done it with.
And he took me to the office and sat me down and he went home and changed.
And then he took me around Atlanta to introduce me to the people of Atlanta.
And of course, at CLC at that time, we were at Auburn Avenue here and King's office was right across the street.
So Ed took me in and who do we meet coming in the door?
But YT and Ed says in his jovial kind of way,
oh, why do I like for you to meet our new field secretary?
And why it looked at me and said, oh, I know which one that is.
That's the one from Baltimore.
Of course, when Ed went to someplace else and Ed and Ed and I had a private conversation,
I wanted me to work for SCLC of course, but anyway I said, no, no, no, I'm settled.
But anyway, they were really the truth and hard.
Oh, oh yeah, oh yeah.
And especially if they had Moses and Mary.
Yeah, yeah, and Diane Nash and Charlie.
They had everybody listed in there.
But anyway, we were.
Oh, after why I tried to recruit them.
Oh, oh, then we went back to the office and stuff.
And Ed got the word that I was not to go to the Delta, but to meet Bob Moses in McComb.
So I took off from Atlanta, went to New Orleans, changed trains in New Orleans,
took Illinois Central up to McComb.
At McComb, I was met by George Hitz, who was a local cab driver,
who George became a very good friend of mine.
And incidentally, all through this until today, I don't drive.
So George took me from the train station to CC Bryant's.
I was with Bob Moses and CC was waiting for me.
And I introduced, Bob Moses introduced me around.
I had to get a med Bob Moses, we talked, and I met the locals.
And I met, and I was introduced to Mr. Webb Orange,
who was better known as Super Cool Daddy.
And I was told that Super Cool Daddy was the man
to see, to do everything.
So Super Cool Daddy and I walked on off.
We went first to Mama Cotton's house on Wall Street, set up a housing,
set up a deal to pay her, went to Mr. Plevis's to restaurant and miss Quinn,
set up a little thing to pay down, went down,
and opened up a bank account in SNCC's name in the town.
And an account at the stationery store where I rented a
memograph machine and stem solos and white out and all of the stuff.
We were doing business with the city because that was part of the plans
that we had thought about.
I mean, you do bend this, you.
They kind of look at it in a different kind of way we thought.
But anyway, we went on and we got set up
and over top of Burglund High School, over top of Burglund Supermarket
was the Messade Temple.
We set up a school there where we were encouraging people to come in.
Well, we did canvassing.
And it was my own fears, but I was canvassing in the projects with some of the local kids.
And there was some workmen.
I could see them in this ground, in this sewer hole, in this ground hole.
They were workmen, they'd minding their business, but they were white men.
I was thinking that they knew what I was doing.
So I was unconscious of them every moment.
To almost the point that I forgot about the kids that I had with me.
But that was about the one or only time that I had that kind of a fear.
And they weren't paying any attention to me.
So I got over that and then we went on and we set up the school.
And in the school, the law of the state was,
you had to interpret the Constitution of Mississippi in order to register the vote.
You had to be able to read it and then interpret.
And the way the registrar would do it when you come down,
he would take the Constitution and flip the pages and turn to any page in the book
and say, write that, read that.
And if my interpretation is not what you would expose to be, then you fail.
So we had the first of all teach people to read and write.
We had to encourage people to come for the reasons that they were coming for.
Then after we get them to read and write and be able to have the courage to pass
to even take the test, it encouraged them to go down.
So that's when Bob Moses would say that we'd have to always stick with these people
and walk with them wherever they go.
And that's when we started taking them down to the registrar's office.
And Bob Moses got beaten and later on, of course, Herbert Lee, Herbert Lee got killed
in the cotton gin by State Representative E.H. Hurst.
And that's when the kids, when the kids start sitting in,
and the kids start doing direct action in the town got involved.
Because one of the things that I was told in one of my first training sessions was that
we were not going into these cities to stay.
You were going to either duplicate yourself or leave something there in order for people to hang on to
or put them in touch with, put a group together that could connect with SNCC that could
support any activity that's going on.
But you want to go in and build something and leave something, not to go and make a home there.
So the...
So it was coming from the...
... came from Ella.
From the reason from the bottom up.
I mean, if you go in and thinking you know it all and you're going to stay there
and forever to do it, you ain't passing on enough and you ain't teaching nothing.
You ain't building nothing.
You just building your own kind of whatever you're looking for.
You aren't giving anything to anybody.
So it was always important to know that what you're doing is you're building things for somebody else to build on.
So you're always working yourself out of a job.
So of course the kids got involved and they started sitting in and everything.
And Curtis and Hollis, Curtis Hayes and Hollis Watkins and Bobby Talbert and I think Brenda Travis,
a couple of others went down to the bus station I think it was and got arrested.
And a game Bob Moses said that we had to support these kids and we also could use the PR like we leave them in for certain amount of time.
And then we'd bail them out because we could use the PR and stuff.
But Bob Moses said somebody's got to go and make sure that they feel comfortable in jail and this was the first time that they had done that.
So I got elected to go and visit them in the jail.
They were down in Magnolia.
I got together with George Hitz who said as I got in a car as we're driving from Pike County down to Magnolia.
He pulls out a silver handle pistol and says don't worry about a thing.
Sit tight.
So we rode down to Magnolia and I was dressed and one of the things when we started I was snick you were always supposed to be dressed in certain tie.
You're always supposed to be giving off another kind of image.
So that day I was into my black suit looking like a lawyer or a minister or whatever and I had my attitude case.
And it's I never will forget him.
It's old but tobacco chewing guy was sitting on the sea outside of this the stairwell going up to the stairs and he's and I walked up and he says never what you want.
And I looked him dead and he I was kind of like he was sitting on this stoop kind of and I was looking him dead in the eye and I says my name is Reginald Robinson.
I'm a field secretary for the student of the foreign coordinating committee.
I'm here to see and I pulled out my list and I said here to see Curtis as well.
Thank you.
You want them know the niggas.
I will not let you up in here and I didn't see anything else of any turns and he goes and he opens his first door and a door slams behind me.
He opens this second door and the door slams behind me.
We go up these stairs and the door slams behind me.
We go in and I finally see Curtis and Hollis and they were they I like this and he opens up the cell and he the jail opens up the cell and he lets me in right.
And so I talked to him and get all the information and cool down and they wonder what the hell I mean.
And I'm telling them what I'm there for just to give you this support and let you know what they say when I have your black ass go get out of here.
So when I got got finished interviewing them everything I turned and I said jailer.
And he came and said what the hell you were.
This is I'm ready to leave and he opened the door.
And of course everybody and each door opened and I walked back out and I went back and I made my report that everybody was fine.
Called into Julian Bond and everything was fine and everybody was going to hang with me at gave my report and everybody was feeling great.
Well that's just some of the stuff that I had to do.
And well I was mainly responsible for the people of everybody.
You know making sure that the vendors were paid and stuff like that.
Were you able to do this Brenda Travis and the other girls for you and the others so they let you see them?
No I didn't see them.
We were giving out where we could.
Sure.
Well I'm in first part a lot of these people that I met that was involved in the Civic Interest Group were kids from West Baltimore.
And of course the white kids were upper class and everything else.
So I was from East Baltimore so that was kind of a strike one.
I had to do a little proving of who I was and kind of make ground and make room for myself.
I met when I met certain people certain things opened up for me.
The demonstrations in Baltimore were really hilarious.
I more or less became in charge of like coordinating the activities at some point.
We had at the height of things when we brought when we made the local restaurant association come into conversation for about a two week period.
We had three renults that we would pile anywhere from seven to eight people in each renult.
And at lunchtime go to the biggest restaurants in Baltimore.
And before being arrested of course they had to read you the Miranda Act.
So they would come to the police and go and shut down the restaurant.
The police would walk in and read the Miranda and then if you walk out then you weren't arrested.
So we would go back and get into the renult and go to another restaurant.
And the police would go, so we had the police department going, we had the restaurant people throwing all up.
And so finally the restaurant to us is, let's talk to these crazy people.
Well of course some of them was getting arrested there also and that's also when the NAACP also said that it was in the public accommodations bill was in the courts.
And it wasn't necessary for all of this activity to be going on.
And I'm only going to mention this person's name one time.
His name is Mr. William "Little Willie" Adams.
He came to our rescue in terms of helping us with bond because his man, the Dixon bond bailman was under his...
...privileged, and he came out.
His wife was also went to the house legislature.
So he was a very political person.
And he was the one that continued to support the students and their activities.
The sit-ins around Baltimore was not...
...nobody really got tossed around or really done in like they did.
I mean you got called names and stuff like that.
I can't recall anybody really getting hurt or really being rough.
When we got to South Baltimore, we got a little ugly and we got into little Italy, we got a little scared.
But you know, basically Baltimore was not like going into a lunch counter in McComb or going into a lunch counter in Atlanta.
When we went into the Peachtree Manor, we'd go with Gingo O'Dingo.
And they threw us out so it's about the same.
But Baltimore was...well, Baltimore for me at that point was my stepping ground and how I was going to make it my way.
And I met and was supported by some very good people when the voter registration activity kind of started.
The reason I got into a position of treasurer which became a small stipend kind of position because of Mr. Harry, Troy Brailey, Troy Brailey, who was the Union representative, AFL-CIO, Union representative, who just so happens knew my father.
Just so happens was on this advisory committee to the students.
But he was one of those people that came around and saw a little clone drink somebody back there and he took me on his wing and showed me some few things.
And then I wound up being okay.
There was Miss Oliver, Mrs. Elizabeth Murphy Oliver who was a writer for the Washington, for the (Baltimore) Afro-American newspaper.
And she was also part of the (Baltimore) Afro-American newspaper family and her daughter, Marcia, were also a big influence in my getting ahead in things because they would introduce me to certain people.
They would take me to certain parties.
So once I got involved in intersnick, things began to come around me and come to me that I took advantage of.
And it all wasn't deal with the demonstrations because I became a worker for the situation.
And so when the guys called for who was ready to give up school and do this number, this larger number that we were talking about doing, I had no fear about signing on because it felt like I was doing the same thing I was doing in Baltimore.
Not thinking the fear or the repercussions or whatever, I mean the same repercussions in Baltimore could have been killed, could have been locked up, could have been anything else.
So Baltimore was the beginning in a lot of ways.
My dad was proud. My mom, another person I'll mention that helped me a lot was the guy named Larry Steele.
It used to be a stringer for jet magazine and Ebony. Larry and I became very, very good friends.
And one of the things that I had to promise my father when I signed on to this was that, of course he was big.
He said, don't worry about me, we'll call your mom every other week and stuff like that.
So this relationship with Larry became a lot, Larry on his runs or coming through Baltimore and stuff.
I would see Larry more than I would talk to my mom. So Larry would stop by and talk to my mom and soothe her about everything was okay and he'd just talk to me and where I was and what I was doing.
So my mom's was as cool as moms could be. I guess my sister was proud of me. I don't know what my brother really thought of me because I don't think he really understood what I was doing or where I was going or the chances I was taking.
What I said to him as I left was that if I survive where I'm going, I'm going to be alright the rest of my life.
And I said it's looking to you today and I'm pretty wealthy.
You had that foresight about what that was missing?
No. I didn't have a foresight at that time but I could fit it into what I had already done in Baltimore for about a year and the kinds of games and kinds of stuff I've seen people do and manipulations and activities.
So when this opportunity came along I said well what the heck? What's the worst can happen? I can make it or not.
So once we got into the stuff in in in McComb and the kids of course all the other activities that went on and things and then when the kids walked out of school that particular day was the worst day even for us because it really it really brought to mind that they were really down to get us.
One of the things that they had they had a warrant out a real warrant out for Diane Nash at that particular moment.
So the night before that everybody was everybody was in town all 16 of us was in town Bob Moses Zona had not gotten into McComb just yet.
He was still in the line of begging to come in and we and we and McComb begging him not to come in because we we singing and praying because we know we're getting ready to face.
So finally that night he came on in. So that next day we all up in the office.
Faintly we hear in the background this sound and it's getting louder and louder and then we we we know what it is.
So being who we are we've always been prepared for demonstration stuff so we broke open the signs and everything and came down and made assignments and stuff and came down on the street and met the kids and march with them into town because everybody took their positions.
My position that time was to observe I could get close to enough to see what was going on and then report to you to get to a telephone and and and and in those days to get a telephone you had to go through an operator to get out otherwise.
So I put the call in before the march started and Julian Bond was holding. I think Charlie Jones was down at Dr. Anderson's house because Dr. Anderson having the only doctor's phone could go straight out.
So we left Diane Nash in the Masonic temple because we didn't want her to get get caught. Everybody else took up positions and went downtown well by that time you know all hell broke loose.
They jumped on Bob Moses and they got everybody and me and then things kind of moved back up.
Bob Moses was on the job jump jump jump jump jump down Bob Moses's on the then then I think Moses covered him and I think make do cover him and a couple of us covered.
They keep him from killing everyone and they pulled him off and they worked him to more and but anyway we finally got everybody out and back to Wall Street.
But now in the meantime while everything is going on I'm in I'm upstairs in the Masonic temple looking down.
The police come by and pick up (Charles) Sherrod and Cordell Reagon.
In the meantime I see the big sergeant walking up the stairs to the Masonic temple inside the Masonic temple is a guy from Detroit by the name of A.G. Gaston and Diane Nash.
So I look at this back door and I'm in there all of this stuff is coming to me as this sergeant is big I forget his name but he's a big one and he was coming up the steps and I looked at this black cloth at the back of the Masonic temple.
I don't know nothing about the Masons, but somehow another I thought that if we got through that black space we would be safe.
So I told Diane Nash and Gaston come with me we got through the black space and open the door and where we were on the roof.
But this cop walked all around the Masonic temple all around and went back out.
I told Gaston that's the job he cool Gaston couldn't wait he got excited he jumped off the roof and they caught him out on a highway.
Well I got Diane Nash back inside we got on a worked out way on the Wall Street and as I said everybody got together then the decision was to make that this was a little too hot for us and so we could make decisions so we decided to go back to Atlanta.
That's when we found out the next day the message on the Wall Street snake house snake gun snuck.
No we never did but we went back to Atlanta and gathered at BB Beaman's and made the decisions of what we were going to do.
Bob Moses I think it was Bob Moses Moses and Chuck McDew was going back into Mississippi.
Charlie Jones and and (Charles) Sherrod and Cordell Reagon was going down to Southwest Georgia.
I was sent up to coordinate on route 50th group 40 with with core and then assignments were made.
While I'm working out coordinate route 40 with core I get this call from Ruby Doris (Smith) Robinson.
This is get over to the core office.
We got a four or five people of ours that just got into the core office saying that they go in somewhere to demonstrate they ain't never demonstrated in their life and baby baby go find out what's going on.
I go over to the core office there's all of these people from New York.
There's Faith Holsaert there's I'm probably going to get a blinded kill steam and there's Peggy Dammond, there's Angela Butler.
And we were joined by Bill Hansen who had just demonstrated in a dappless you didn't come out of New York out of New York and then there was a couple of local ball of mouth folk.
The intentions was to go to Crisfield, Maryland sit in at the governor and then Governor Tawes restaurant in Crisfield, Maryland.
This is at Christmas time 61 and they and they knew we're going to get put out.
I said they had a theme of there was no room in the end.
So I'm trying to tell them you know are you all ready for this you know what can happen you haven't had any train and what what the only one in the group to hand in was Angela Butler because she was a part of the national group.
She had been there living in New York.
Well we get on buses and we go down here we go into Chrisfield and we're going to Governor Tawes as a place they read the Miranda act but they decide that they ain't got trees like they do in ball of war after they read the Miranda act they like that as a job.
No one no one and this is the first and only time in the six years that I was with snake that I got locked up that's the only time that I ever got locked up.
Yeah so then we we they take us to Princess Anne, Maryland and then of course overnight and everything and then (Juanita) Mitchell again.
The Mitchell family becomes our attorneys.
In the meantime we meet Freddie St. Clair and Walter Black.
Walter Black from Eastern Maryland and Freddie St. Clair from Cambridge, Maryland.
They are the bonds, billsments.
We decide again to stay in the amount of time to get to PR and everything.
I got out to do PR and went to New York and everywhere and started doing things and and getting raising money and the rest of the stuff that we did when somebody was in and getting bail and everything lawyers and all of that kind of stuff.
In the meantime I'm I'm knowing Freddie St. Clair.
So we get everybody out and we all go to New York for Christmas but there's discussion about whether we're going to do about Cambridge or what are we going to do about the Eastern Shore not necessarily Cambridge.
But we have now this invitation from Freddie St. Clair to come into Cambridge and that they would support us.
So we discussed this in New York over the holidays and of course we in touch with Atlanta and it's decided that Cambridge we were going to Cambridge and take a look see.
So that's when they asked Bill Hansen to become a secretary and he went back to Cambridge with me.
Well first the civic interest group, Nagout of Washington, all of the, all of the, let's put it this way, all of the snake affiliates that was in the area was asked to mobilize and come in on weekends.
We used to have just weekend demonstrations in Cambridge.
We continued to do that until the community started doing damage getting involved in the demonstrations.
Then it became as Cambridge began to grow it became a spot and everybody wanted the spot.
But again our rule was we build, we grow, we leave.
Cambridge had a very strong organization.
Freddie gave up the organization early on because not only Freddie was in business his dad was the funeral director.
So he was in business so the business became much more important than being chairman of a civic organization where you got to be going to meetings and running around.
So then his cousin Gloria Richardson steps in.
Now the same class has got an old history of Cambridge where the great, great granddaddy was the first city councilman or own slaves.
I don't know something like that, but he was way, way, way, way, way back.
So when Gloria took over it was another kind of scene.
So we had somebody that also do something about business and some about organization and stuff.
So we built some other people around her that the organization became organized enough to deal and negotiate with the national guard and Kennedy and everything else.
So we began to say, Ruby Doris (Smith) Robinson, I think we need to, you know, back off.
Well, before we could do that, the white establishment said that they were going to hold a referendum on public accommodations.
Gloria said that no black folks was going to vote for the referendum.
I said, you can't do that.
She said, this is Cambridge.
I can do anything I want to do.
I says, no, you can't because you are an affiliate of snake.
We got people dying in the South for road voter registration. We got people getting locked up.
We got, how does it look and affiliate up here, advocating no vote when all of this activity is going on?
She says, well, I run this one. That says, no. You may think you run it.
So of course, I went back to the board. Now, I went to the board that we had built in Cambridge and explaining what I was saying.
And they said, of course, we got the vote.
What was her position? What? And why they shouldn't vote.
Because there was enough white people to vote for the referendum in order for black folks not to have to vote for it to pass.
So black folks wasn't necessarily for black folks to participate in order for it to become law.
Which may or may not have been, there's more registered white folks that that could have happened.
But the point of it was, we could not stay out of a vote no matter what the outcome would be.
Whether they were both or not, we couldn't stay out of the vote.
So of course, that became a vote of contention.
And then it was sort of, at that point, we were getting ready to have a conference in Atlanta.
And Ruby asked me to stop it all of the black campuses to build Hanson and I to stop it all of the black campuses.
Black and white campuses coming down to talk up the conference coming up.
Now, I worked with Bill Hansen in Cambridge, Maryland.
And Hanson's white. I've always felt that Hansen was hiding from his own community.
Because if he was daring enough to do the shit that he did in our community, then I'm quite sure he could have convinced some white folks to come on and understand what was going on.
He had a very arrogant kind of attitude about the way he would express himself.
Like when we were in New York, he hadn't even really become a secretary yet.
But Angela Butler at that time had become a star almost.
She was on Jack Carson and she had already been in the Juilliard School of Music.
So she was on her way so they knew people. Peggy was into drama and stuff.
These kids were going places. So they knew people.
When we got to New York, we were at a party with people like Godfrey Cambridge and Barbara Tia and even there was Sal Mineo there.
But at this party, somebody came to me and said, hey man, you got to get your man in check.
He just caused Sal Mineo to leave.
I said, what are you talking about?
The way that he came on to him about what's going on and saying that you got all of it.
I mean, he was just so rough until he just made the man feel bad and just left.
Well, when we left New York going back to Cambridge, there was no reason.
And we're going out at night going into being picked up in the Cambridge at night.
There was no reason for Bill Hansen to announce or as we getting on the bus going to New York, what we're going, where we going and what we're going to do.
When we got to Cambridge on these weekend things when we go to the Choptank Inn, the reporters would always come to me saying, hey, red, you're going to New York.
You're going to the Choptank Inn with Bill Hansen? I say, hell no.
I said, well, I know. I said, even if the Choptank Inn opened them all, I wouldn't go in there and get nothing.
Not even going to carry out.
But if that's what he thinks he needs to do, and that's what he needs to do.
And he would go in there and get hit upside to here with iron chairs and bottles and get thrown through the windows.
And each week he would go back and I would tell him, that ain't necessary to do.
You don't have to do that.
So we would have these kinds of things.
So when we got to Virginia Union, Reggie Green, who's now a minister in Washington, DC, said to me, say, baby, if you're going to too many more out of schools, you're going to lose out.
I said, well, you're talking about it. And then he started talking about how Bill was.
So and I had been complaining to Ruby.
So Ruby says, okay, here's what we do. We split you up.
He goes to the White campuses. You go to the Black campuses.
So we split up.
So I then went on to Livingstone College and other colleges to talk up the conference.
I went from Atlanta to some, I think the guy's name was Johnson or something like that.
Anyway, he was a young minister. He was a young divinity student.
He smuggled me on campus.
And I stayed on campus for maybe about two weeks before they found me.
I moved around the city and did a report. I'm sorry, we can't find it.
And I did all of the topographical stuff about the Air Force Academy and what was important was I met 12 ministers and we called them the 12 high.
I also met (Amelia) (Amelia) Boynton. (Amelia) Boynton, then I was there.
So I made my report and then I went on to the other colleges and then after our conference in making new assignments,
it was decided that Bernard Lafayette would go to to to to Selma because of these 12 ministers.
Because him being a young minister, he would relate better to what we have established as the leadership.
So him and Colia (Liddell) Lafayette, I think, went on in there and that's when the other activities began to happen.
And I knew there was a ministerial connect to the cabinet for all these things.
Yeah, that's how it happened.
That's how it happened.
Because we used to hang out at the at the doing call, the chicken chat.
In Selma.
And then I sneak back on campus.
Really go back and ask you a couple things.
So in the column, you left in Bob Moses's house and you all not wanting him to come and he wanted to come and then he got jumped.
Not everybody's going to have that picture of Bob Moses's house.
Can you explain what the issue is with him for people who don't know?
Well, we weren't we weren't too sure what was going down.
But we knew that if we knew from other experiences that if we had a white boy up on this march, it was going to be a lot rougher than what it was going to be.
So we were trying to keep the roughness down.
But Bob Moses was insisting of course his position is being a part of us.
And he wanted to be there.
And we think that we don't quite want to ask this cake this bad.
And that was the same kind of thing that I go back with Bill Hansen.
But Bob Moses Zona was far different than a Bill Hansen.
Bob Moses was a person that was very interested in talking and moving with his community.
He was not trying to hide.
And his credentials was much different than Bill Hansen.
But the only thing was that at that time we just felt as though it had been a lot easier on the situation if he did not come.
But now Bob Moses has been there really pushed the envelope because it aggravated the policeman and they saw this white boy up in there.
And they just couldn't help themselves.
Oh yeah they wanted to kill him.
They wanted to do him in.
But yeah so that was the only thing.
We were just trying to keep it from being as rough as it was.
How did you all view the fact that when you were young people and you go into McComb and then you know it is that we are doing like a month.
How did you all cope with that?
Well when we first heard about it that was our first experience with realities of stuff that we had done.
Our first reaction was to run.
But then we had a long conversation with Amzie Moore.
And Amzie Moore pointed out that we wanted to think that we had to do was to show that again that we were not afraid and that we were in support of what we were talking about doing.
As the same thing was going down and seeing the kids in jail.
So Amzie suggested that we have that the funeral become a mass meeting and that we do the mass meeting.
Well Bob Moses and if I remember right Bob Moses and McDew were on the platforms talking.
Sharrod and Jones were just milling in the crowd.
I had the assignment of taking a picture of Louis Allen who I didn't know.
But Dr. Anderson knew and I and Doc I walked with Dr. Anderson until he spotted Allen.
And then as I pointed to camera to Mr. Allen, Mr. Allen, I almost took my head off but we got to his picture.
And then later on of course Mr. Allen was killed.
But our position our first position was of course to run because we were looking at death ourselves.
But then Amzie convinced us that we had to stay.
And that was the same kind of position we did.
I guess when we got together and went back to Atlanta it was so devastating and we were so strong apart.
We couldn't put ourselves together there in McComb.
We had to get stretched out.
And that's when James Forman came into play.
That's when we really started organizing and and and and Snake became a little more organized.
I mean we had somebody to answer to.
I mean even though we would I mean Ruby was was a commando and you could call Ruby and you could get the right connections about doing things.
You weren't afraid of being well I traveled a lot on my own.
I wasn't afraid of not ever being connected with my home base.
I was never afraid of being caught out there and not being covered.
But then when James Forman came in things started to organize a little better.
And then you saw yourself moving in a different kind of direction.
And then I began to be used in different kinds of ways.
And Ruby was playing that role.
She's actually doing things right?
Just about.
And she said no to watch line and she's giving directions and moving us around and stuff.
Yeah.
James Forman, James Forman for me.
Jim for me of course.
So people who don't know can you talk about Amzie Moore and you see who he was and who wrote?
Amzie Moore was an old post office person.
He was a military, he was first of all he was a military.
And he was a soldier and he came home.
Of course all of the stuff that he met in Mississippi he couldn't deal with.
He was a postal worker and he still wasn't getting satisfaction.
He became involved with the NAACP.
He was just a person that continued to try and find his freedom wherever he lived.
And he was a person who was unafraid of the possibilities of his actions.
He just went on and did what he thought was necessary to be done.
And what he did was he hooked up with other people of the same light and began to organize and do things.
And when the idea of when him and Bob Moses talked and the idea of us coming in and doing things,
they thought about, you know, Bob Moses of a county might have been a little rougher to get started in than a place like McComb where there was other possibilities and other resources.
Because all of these guys, Amzie Moore and C.C. Brian and O. Supercool Daddy,
all of these men within the state knew each other, Aaron Henry and all of these people.
So we weren't walking into anything new.
We were walking into something that was already built.
It just needed a little, I guess, workers.
And so when Bob Moses went in and then they decided to, that the plan was to go to Mississippi, go to McComb.
Well, even after that, Amzie continued to be an advisor of how to go about doing things and where to go and what to do and what to say and just gave us the skinny on Mississippi.
And how to conduct yourself and how to protect yourself.
And he was a tall man.
I know that he mentioned you were the first person you joined by a lawyer in the town.
Am I remembering that?
How do you always say that?
Are you saying that at one point a bomb?
Later on after we left.
I think it was after we left.
I know because I was gone.
I was gone then.
You've already described that you were involved in the sitting and the balls more and also about the registration.
And you mentioned Snickers debating the school in that summer of 16 years.
Can you talk about what that debate was about and what you thought?
Well, at the time I wasn't too sure as to what the debate was all about.
Because as I looked at direct action, we were going into lunch counters and other places going into stores trying to close and being more direct about what we're saying is not happening.
Well, in the same sense that if you dealing with voter registration and you attempt to register the vote, they're going to hit you in the head.
So I don't know how more direct than that gets.
So I didn't really see the difference in whether I was operating on voter registration or operating on direct action.
When we were in, when I had left McComb and started dealing with Cambridge, Cambridge was more dealing with accommodations and direct action.
But it was a lot more intense than what I was doing in Mississippi because I didn't have to put up with the National Guard in Mississippi.
That was somebody else that had to deal with that in Mississippi.
But in confronting Bobby Kennedy in Mississippi was the same as Confront and Bobby Kennedy in McComb and in Cambridge, Maryland.
Where in Cambridge, Maryland, after a meeting, he told me he says he was handing out there was a little PT 9 votes that his brother used to run.
They were tire clips, right? So he said to me, he says, I would give you one, but you know where I tie.
I said, well, your wife folks been hanging me long enough. I ain't go anywhere no tie for you to get me.
And he turned red, of course. But you know, he says, I remember John Doar talking about you from Mississippi.
I said, well, that's all I am. We meet again.
And well, this time we met in person when it was in Cambridge.
But he had heard about me in McComb through John Doar.
Well, one night in Mississippi, Bob Moses had taken this guy down to register the vote and then he didn't register, but we needed an affidavit.
So we had to go out to his house to get the affidavit.
There was Bob Moses Moses, John Doar, (Marion) Barry Barry, and me, and George Heads.
We went out to this guy's house in this open field. And George says, of course, you're all wait till I give the word that I got him, that he comes out.
Because the old man was sitting there with his shotguns, and when he realized who we were, he cut the light on.
You've been in Mississippi.
You know, when there's ain't nothing to wreck, just like this.
There's one of these up over top of you, and you sitting in a nothing out there with darkness.
We sat there and talked with this man for, I don't know, how many hours to convince him to give us an affidavit.
One of the things that the man said to me, said to us was, I'm really afraid because you never know what these white folks are going to do.
You never know where they are. They might be out there in the darkness, or you go out there to your cow, and they turn green and they jump on you.
Well, for years, (Marion) Barry and I, every time we would see each other, we would greet each other with, watch out to the white folks, my turn green.
But to just demonstrate between Mississippi and Cambridge, I mean, I was still dealing with the Justice Department in one hand.
And then another story about John Doar was when John Hardy, who was the second person that came into Mississippi, came into work with Bob Moses.
There were some people down in Walthall, and he went to work with the people in Walthall, and he got locked up.
Well, they beat John pretty bad.
And when John saw John Doar coming into the cell block or somewhere, he kind of reached out for him, and John Doar kind of gave the hint about, you don't know me.
And then later on, of course, John spoke with him and got whatever necessary.
But John Hardy was very, very hurt that he was snubbed by John. Well, John Doar became a good friend, I mean, over the years.
We did a lot of stuff together, even showed up in Cambridge again, because when things got hot, there was a guy in the Justice Department by the name of Hubbard that went to school with Pop Herb, and Pop Herb St. Clair went to Lincoln University.
And Hubbard was in the Justice Department, and so John Doar brought Mr. Hubbard in to Cambridge to talk to Pop Herb to see if we could get things calm down.
And if you know Pop Herb, every second word Pop Herb was, you pig fucker.
So we had relationships with the Justice Department in different kinds of ways.
So the work in Mississippi and the work in Maryland didn't differ but so much.
But I guess, well, it both had the same dangers, as it always had.
And anyway, when the voter education project came out, the YEP project came out.
Well, I had worked a couple other projects before this, but after Mississippi and Alabama and everybody got the money, there was a little penny piece of money left for a project in Orangeburg, South Carolina.
So we had been wanting to get back in Orangeburg to check it out and see what's going on.
But the people of Orangeburg, the NAACP and all of the adult folks saying, we don't want none of them to sneak people in here.
And this is before Cleveland gets shot and everything else. We don't want it.
But they said, and Randolph Blackwell, who was working with YEP at the time, who was also a professor in the HBC kind of situation.
He got together, I think, with Dr. Thomas at State, South Carolina State, and then they worked out a situation where I would come in, and would be doing, would take the voter registration list that they had.
And the captains that they had in their organization and make a, put the captains with people, the voting people in the list so that on Election Day, this captain would have known everybody that votes before computers.
So this captain would know everybody in his precinct, and then these people would be broken down in precinct, and these are your eligible voters.
So they promised that we would come in and do that and do that only.
And they also wanted the money to come in from VEP, also, because State would get a little piece of it, and they would see if we would get a little piece of it.
But they had to take us in this thing.
So I had, I wanted to go on all over the state before I could get this job done, and even go down to Charleston, South Carolina, to talk to the president, Mr. Charlie Brown, and all the people of the NAACP of Orangeburg, and their advisory council.
I mean, it was just a hard part of stuff. So we set up this little house, and we started going to work.
But of course, I recruited a couple of students to come over and help out.
And in the meantime, I found out that there was a problem with the cafeteria.
And at the time, there was a guy named Pete Bryant, who was our representative from South Carolina to SNCC.
And of course, I mean, I couldn't be a SNCC representative in town without conversing with Pete.
I was never seen on a Claflin campus, or a state's campus.
I could go to a state's campus because I could meet with Dr. Thomas.
But I couldn't be seen on Claflin's campus because there was nobody I was supposed to be seeing there.
But one day, somehow another of the cafeteria just broke out, and somehow another of the other demonstration that I was not even in town.
So I was nowhere in sight, nowhere around.
Came back a couple days later, but anyway.
So those are just some of the things.
And then I hooked up with, they sent me in to work with the Northern Student Movement.
Dottie Burlage had a project in Raleigh out of the Northern Student Movement.
And they sent me in to kind of support her on her situation.
Jane Stembridge, I knew her for a very short period of time.
But she came later.
She came later.
Ash.
You mentioned the National Guard in Cambridge.
Can you talk about what they were doing in there and how that worked?
Well, by the time the city, the local folk took over,
they had really closed the town down.
And I think the mayor of the city got terribly upset.
And he felt as though the state police was not doing what it was supposed to be doing, pardon me.
And of course, being the eastern shore of Maryland,
and the Tawes and all of the water men,
the eastern shore has a very big influence on the state of Maryland.
So then it was decided that I guess it was getting completely on a hand
that they would send in the National Guard to squal this situation.
Well, they sent in a general by the name of George Gelston.
And George became an ally.
Because we would have meetings, me, him, Gloria, Fred Weisgal,
who was one of our lawyers.
We would have meetings in Baltimore at Fred Weisgal's house about strategies
of what we were going to do.
The guard was in there for to squal things.
And I kept telling George that that was not going to do it.
That was only going to make things worse.
One of the things that happened between George and I
was that after we got up some kind of relationship,
he said to me, you know, you're a very interesting person.
I like to have you as an officer.
As a George, I can't be no officer.
I can't even be in your arm.
And he says, oh, come on. What did you talk about?
He says, what's your status?
I said, we need my status.
I said, I'm four F.
Is it you four F?
I said, yep.
I said, I'm mentally incompetent.
He says, come on.
You know, he's talking to the adjective general of the national,
oh, Merle National God.
He says, you know, I can check you out.
That's your prerogative to do that.
Four F. So he let it go.
So a few minutes later, he says, you did that, didn't you?
I said, well, I did what?
He says, you are really four F.
And you're mentally incompetent.
I said, well, I told you. You didn't believe me.
He says, if you don't mind, could you tell me what happened?
I said, well, I went down to your army.
And there was this sergeant.
And this sergeant put these boards up in front of me.
And he said, these are inkplots.
Tell me what you see.
I said, inkplots.
The sergeant said, no, you look at them.
And these are inkplots.
You look at them.
And you see something in them.
Tell me what you see.
I said, I see inkplots.
So the sergeant says, no, you don't understand.
I said, yes, I do.
If I'm going to be in your army and you tell me that they inkplots,
I'm going to bleed that they inkplots.
Incompetent.
Joseph said.
So Joseph said, I don't know how you did it, but I didn't.
Well, let's go pass that, George.
So we would do things like, George would say,
Rich, don't have the demonstration this time.
I said, George, I got to, we pushed against the wall.
He says, well, if you got to do it, let's go down to this certain point.
You kneel and pray.
And then I hold my boys off.
You kneel and do your little thing and then you go on back.
We did that a couple of times, right?
And things went well.
But one time we did it, and George was out of town.
His next in charge was Colonel Tawes, the nephew of the governor.
We get to the point where we're going to stop and pray.
Cliff Voss, one of our most distinguished people,
decided that he's going to charge these young white, fixed banets,
Eastern Shore crackers.
They grab him and go stab him or hell breaks loose.
They shoot tear gas, muster gas that night, all over the town,
especially the black town, black section of town, all over everywhere.
So of course, Courtland, Stokely and several other people got arrested that night.
I was helping people with the Denny lines as a picture of me helping a couple of people
who got shot with canisters.
But anyway, I then went and went with the doctor and finally got Stokely
and everybody out of jail and things settled down again.
And then we went into negotiations again with the National Guard.
We negotiated on a basis that there was no blacks in the National Guard
and there was an offensive kind of attitude towards them.
So a few weeks after that, then this guy named Boxer came, I think he was a Colonel.
He came down as Georgia's second in the command.
He was a black guy out of Baltimore.
So then they integrated to the National Guard.
So then the National Guard became set back as an observer of the negotiating team.
And we began to negotiate with the city and with the National Guard.
That's when Bobby Kennedy started coming in a little more.
And so that's my estimation of George.
But George played a very vital role in keeping things together.
Because before he came in, there was going to be a clash between the black and white community.
And everybody knows that everybody down there is a hunter.
And so nobody was really afraid of nobody down there.
Once the word was out.
And it was very difficult to keep a cap on things.
Because at one point in time, there was this open field that buttressed the black and white community.
And one night, the white folks was trying to come across the field and open fire.
And then the fire was returned and you didn't have that no more.
One night, you could hear the car start as it came around racetrack and started at the end.
And raced up the street and shot you could hear shots going off.
And it goes up and you could hear it spin around.
And as it came back, it came back.
You could hear it open fire, but you heard fire return.
You could hear that motor going on out of town.
So it was becoming very, very dangerous.
Because there was nothing in between to stop.
That's from really happening, except that the guard was there to hold back the situation which allowed that talking to happen.
At that time, and also in Cambridge, we made a lot of promises and a lot of slow down on things.
Because I'm not criticizing Robert C. Weaver, who was at the HUD department.
But a lot of promises were made that was going to come into Cambridge.
Gloria was made a lot of promises of things that was going to happen.
That I don't even know whether they've happened today.
But they did give a lot of concession.
And the community still is a very strong community.
And that was our purpose was to leave a strong community.
I heard people saying that Cambridge in many ways was more like organizing in the North after the voting rights that,
you know, the issues were more like the ones that happened later.
Does that make sense to you?
You know, there was more like about jobs and access.
Well, that's where it came from from the beginning.
I mean, it was sort of like the March on Washington about jobs.
I mean, jobs were leaving from down there.
Folks had to go as far away as Delaware at the work.
There was several factories that had closed the Campbell factory.
It closed down there.
And the watermen were not really functioning.
I mean, and black watermen were making a lot of money.
And so the job situation was poor.
The school situation was terrible.
And everything that you could probably name would be in the mix.
Yeah.
He talked about this a little bit.
Can you describe what kind of person was it?
Is this the way or the kind of leader?
Gloria was...
I don't want to say chrismatically to her.
But she followed orders to a certain degree in the beginning.
She had a sense of leadership coming from the people.
As far as I knew she was listening to what was demands coming out of her board.
Because she would meet with her board.
And her board would give her directions as to what to go on.
But then somewhere in this life, I guess she took on another kind of thing
when she started running with people like Jessie, Jessie out of New York.
I can't think of Jesse's name.
But the whole act group.
And she earned her name correctly.
And I think she's in recent years.
She's may have gotten a few things out of kilter.
But I think without her taking over from her cousin.
And the name of St. Clair being what it was.
That's what made the Cambridge movement what it was.
And she deserves every bit of accolades and support for her activities
for building such an organization.
And she was a very talented person.
But can you say more about what the position was of the NW-2P?
Well, that was very basic.
Because once we had gone and sat in and we had a number of cases in court.
The air position was, we got this in court the same as what the air position has always been.
We got this in court now.
So there's no need of spending any money of your kids going out there doing these things
and making us spend money to get you out of jail.
Well, our position was we had to push the envelope because you've been sitting on the court action.
And if the court action ain't happening then some kind of action has got to happen
to make the court action happen.
So we said we're going to go ahead on.
So I would imagine that they thought that we were finished.
And then Henry G. Parks Jr came along and gave us life again.
And then the others support us came along.
And we began to move again and we were able to do the things that we were doing.
But as I said, in the beginning I didn't know that what we were doing was building clarences.
And then the people were like, what?
And to run back there then.
But that was the first part of the voter registration activity.
Then it spread it out.
When did you run?
I forgot. I think it was at 60, 63, 62 somewhere around and there.
That early, yeah.
You know, I'm a college part of that football.
So you knew that?
Yeah.
How was she when she went from that school to the New Golfing?
Well, I had a little something to do with it.
Of course, when the group came back to Baltimore for a meeting,
that's when they start meeting everybody.
And that's when normal met folks.
And normal began to find her way to do things.
And then normal sign going to go to Atlanta to work.
And for I know it, she was in.
Yeah.
And Roland.
I think really I thought we did early memories of him and the former and maybe John Hardy.
And that they could all barely fit at the same time in the office.
Mm-hmm.
So that's how I...
Yeah, it's end-ranked.
Yeah.
It's end-ranked.
It was a very small office.
But she come out of Morgan.
I don't know when the normal came out of Morgan or not, but I don't know exactly.
All I remember was that she was...
She was like secretary to Clarence Logan, who we call Clarence Logan.
She was very tight with Clarence...
Well, the leaders at that time was Clarence Logan and Phil Savage,
who was hitting the voter registration stuff.
But then Levin West was the Morgan president.
Just how normal...
I think normal came with Clarence Logan.
And because things became organized once we started doing a voter registration,
it was records to be kept and things to be done.
So there was necessary for a secretary at that time.
Did you know August Meier?
Yes.
Yes, I knew August Meier.
I think I had a bunch of papers over there, so it's Chambler.
If you could read it in hand right, you can always note.
Yes, I was at his funeral.
Oh, yeah?
Yeah.
Chambler, he played a role in a vibe in some of his films.
Well, he was one of...
He was one of the people that was...
I would say there was a party advisory group.
There was an adult group.
There was a touch to Snake.
And August Meier being a teacher out at Morgan was close to the students.
And then there was people like Reverend Bascom.
And Reverend Vernon Dobson and Reverend Frank Williams.
One either Mitchell or Catherine Adams.
And...
These were all the kind of adult advisors.
And when any and everything would go down in any major kind of way,
they would have something to say or some advice to give,
it wasn't always taken.
Like we would use Bascomb's church a lot.
I had to report to Miss Adams as a secretary,
which used a secretary to the advisory group.
So all my records had to be cleared through her to get more money to do whatever.
But August Meier was just a advisor to the group.
He was one of them adult-crown people.
Were you at the Marcos in Washington?
Yes, I was.
Just to show up.
I didn't give me no aside.
I didn't have to do none.
Just find my group and just be with them.
And would you remember them that day?
Singing and eating good food.
And just having a good time that day.
I paid too much to the speaking.
I pissed off because they had already bumped us with what we wanted to say.
So I wasn't too interested in nothing but anybody else had to say.
Did you think of that whole thing about changing the speech?
Well, I thought it was like it is today.
The power is win.
If you want to be in the game, you have to play by their rules.
So did you have anything to do with the pretty duty Richardson?
No, I didn't recruit Judy.
A little sister kind of emerged.
She was one of them people that came down.
She was doing the first bus loads of students that came down to demonstrate on weekends.
And somehow another, she kind of stuck.
And then I looked around one day and I had an all my right side and all my left side.
And she was just doing things.
And we were just moving along and things were happening.
She was useful.
And then the next thing I knew, we were heading on out and I was headed to Atlanta.
She was heading right with me.
And then I think we went to Bill Hansen's wedding.
And from there we went to Atlanta.
And that's when she ran into the big folks.
And then she stayed and then she, she been ever since.
And not knowing that she could type like she did.
No.
Because they were looking for people to sit on that watch line when the reports came through.
Somebody that could take it all down.
I can't really say that I'm responsible for a little sis.
She just happened to come along and latch on and we just went on through.
What latch on to me?
No, I can't think of anything.
Well, it may be a few, but she was one that we just kind of bond it and went on.
Well, (Chuck) McDew and I were very very close and Bob Moses Hansen and I were very close.
Trying to spell them in our very close.
When did parents come in and pick you up?
Oh, and she was with Nag.
Yeah.
Nag was a lot of people.
Well, that point in time was Nag and then it was Nashville.
Several hubs, there was Atlanta and there was a lot of competition between these folks too.
Who else?
Well, I mean.
There was the leadership and who was going to be and who was not going to be.
Who was going to follow true nonviolence?
Who was not violent?
Who wasn't not violent?
You take a fellow like (Chuck) McDew who comes from Massillon, Ohio.
You can't really comfort him into nonviolence.
You might get him to understand a position.
Now, a Bernard Lafayette with his kind of divinity kind of feeling.
I guess Absorb with Jim Lawson was saying in such a different manner,
even though (Chuck) McDew had known also Jim Lawson as well.
That's right.
But (Chuck) McDew as a person is a totally different character than Bernard Lafayette.
But they both could come together under the nonviolent banner and move situations and make things happen.
You didn't go to the meeting in October six years.
You know, like just next to the second meeting, that would have been too bad before you had that leadership.
I didn't get there until I didn't get involved until 61.
You have a sense of why (Chuck) McDew kept getting real interested as Jim,
but it was that people were just wanting about him.
As far as I knew, he had the kind of,
he had the kind of command of loyalties.
I mean, when him and I really got to know each other,
we had certain things in common.
So I took him on as my chairman.
And then with me, it was kind of added to this as the chairman,
he says what goes on.
The same thing happened with when Jim became the executive director,
whatever the boss say, do if you got to go and do this.
But with (Chuck) McDew and I, we became more or less close brothers.
I really don't know where to go with this one.
But...
Probably I was interested because I heard about the competition.
And some people saying that Nick office was in Atlanta because Nashville got the first chair.
And then the question about whether Diane Nash Nash should have been chair of Mary and Mary.
Nick Duce says that he became chair in part because Ella Baker picked him out
because he wasn't lobbying for it.
And that was the factor.
Well, that's kind of...
That's kind of what it was.
He didn't want it.
And there was too much competition between the schools being the schools that they are.
And they became a school competition.
And that's what Ella saw was this competition between them.
And nothing was going to happen of what she was talking about us going out and doing.
But Dew was kind of outside of that.
And he was not a part of them.
So he could bring them together.
So I guess that's always been his explanation about it.
And he's also kind of been outside of them.
I mean, he kind of says,
until I came along,
I was the only other outsider
because I didn't come from any of the traditional pieces.
So he could use me.
We became allies about things and doing things.
So yeah, I mean, they had heavy competition going on.
Heavy.
So this was because you were trying to think
out of the first group, the first 16,
were you in Chuck, the only two that won in the East South?
Well, Chuck was deep South.
Chuck was South Carolina.
I was just thinking about where he grew up.
Oh, they see who he was.
I'm kind of thinking who he was.
Well Paul Brooks was out of Chicago.
And I think his wife, Gwen,
was out of Chicago,
was out of Chicago.
Diane Nash was out of Chicago.
Okay.
Oh, Paul Brooks was like.
Well, very straightly kind of person.
Very bad refact and academia,
you know, one of them kind of straight guys.
If you can imagine my walking into a hotel conference room
for the first time,
and I don't know who they are except for their quick faces,
but I've seen them in the student voice.
And there's my seat.
And my seat is right across from Diane Nash.
And I'm looking her right straight in the face
with my patch over my eye.
And I've never seen such a beautiful woman in it.
I'm paying more attention to it.
I ain't paid attention to nobody else around me.
And later on,
Connie Curry, after I meet Connie Curry,
Connie, touched me on the shoulder and says,
it was a very interesting doodle you had going on there.
I said, will you mean?
She says, I saw you doodle in you and Diane Nash.
And it went to little heart.
And I hadn't realized I was sitting there doodling.
I was sitting in the heart and everything.
And it went when she's just a gorgeous woman.
So then as I began to meet people
and understand what their role was and different kinds of ways,
I began to formulate what I wanted to do.
Before Ella came out on me because I didn't know how
which was going to accomplish what I was going to accomplish.
And then of course when Ella kind of took me in
and then it became a little more open,
I began to talk with Diane Nash and we became friends and everything.
And then it was very interesting when the kids got out of school
and there was the big warring out on her.
My responsibility not only of absorbing what was going on
was to protect Diane Nash and make sure that she didn't get picked up.
So and then over the years we've been good friends.
But yes, Diane Nash was, ooh, Lord.
When a pretty woman ever seen.
What did you think of the position she took the next summer
when she was pregnant?
You know, she was going to jail.
And the Pacifica can you remember that?
Oh yeah, well I just thought Diane Nash was just a brave woman.
I mean, you just go and do anything necessary to be done.
I mean this is a remarkable woman.
She also reminded me of another woman that I met in South Carolina
by a name of Grace Brooks, who was a teacher at South Carolina State,
was also this same kind of very beautiful
and Grace finally left South Carolina State
and joined the Free Southern Theater and acted in that.
And that was the way she wanted to give to whatever she could do.
And then there was people that came around like in a typical in a tongue.
Ooh boy.
Anyway, she'll come back to me.
She married Bill Withers.
She became very, anyway.
We had some very beautiful women in the movement.
And I've tried to always support them and whatever it is that they want to do.
I mean, I didn't want to see Diane Nash go in like that.
And I never wanted to see her get hurt or any of the sisters to get hurt.
But if one of the sisters wanted to make a decision about doing something
they had to back them up.
Because one of the things that I really learned in the movement
that there was some very, very, very beautiful strong sisters and beautiful.
I mean, not only in the facial features of Diane Nash,
but in all of the other ways that beauty can be a story.
I mean, Judy is a wonderful person.
Bobby Yancy, you know, when we first learned how to raise money,
we put the foil group that made us cry about how you had to do this kind of stuff.
But she still did it.
She surely cooks.
She really write cooks who came down and was working in the movement.
And of course, there was nobody like Ruby Nars.
Nobody like Big Mama.
And then there was Jessie Johnson who took care of us with the money
and stuff that made sure we were okay.
It was Connie Curry.
And Casey Hayden.
And all of these people were, well, Casey.
We also thought it was like a movie star.
Yes, Casey's beautiful gal.
You think that she must have been married with her friends?
Oh, yeah.
And so the women that came along, you know,
the gene Will Smiths and the Brenda Travis Travis'
and Mrs. Cotton who we were talking about.
Nobody really knew it, but we lived in a whole house.
I mean, we, well, at the time we didn't know we were in a whole house.
But we were just anxious.
We were glad to have someplace to stay.
And nobody else was ready to take us in.
Until we got to moving around and meeting people.
But that was okay.
Took it, gave us.
And a lot of places like in Cambridge,
it wasn't until I'm going to say the underworld.
It came into, came into understanding what was happening in Cambridge.
Did the local community really?
It was the guys that they always been putting in jail
that started to go on under demonstrations.
There was the guys at Hungin' a pool room that started to come in out of the pool room.
So they made the change.
And then the respectable folks got together and said,
we were going to go on board,
because we got to keep things going
and then things began to operate around.
But it was the underworld.
Why do you think they came off first?
Because they were unafraid.
They were more unafraid than the rest of these folks,
or they have to lose.
They thought they were gaining.
You think they're happy with how it came off?
They're going to be able to get to know each other right some time
and understand there's a few statues around.
But I don't know how well people are eating.
I don't know what the housing situation is.
I don't know whether we own any businesses.
I don't think Pine Street is up again.
I mean, there used to be several businesses,
black businesses on Pine Street.
I don't know that there's any businesses.
So I can't say that people are happy.
I know that people in Mississippi aren't happy.
I mean, they got more black elected officials
in Mississippi than any state in the country.
And it's still a poise state in the country.
Black folks don't own any production companies.
I understand Nissan just went back into Canton.
It seems like, it seems like to me,
with the types of money that's been reported in the black community.
It seems like we can get some kind of institution,
financial institution on a corner
and start building maybe a laundromat or a general store.
Everybody ain't got to go out to Walmart.
I mean, everybody can't get to Walmart.
I mean, just go back to the old general store,
have a filling station on a corner,
have a restaurant where folks can come in
and off the road or in town.
And have some kind of institution, financial institution,
that sits there on that corner, regulates the business,
make sure that money moves around in that community
and then moves out.
I don't understand all the stock exchange and everything,
but I know that when you got money moving around this week
and you got money moving over here and coming back to you,
that you can then go out.
You can sit at the big poker game and afford to play.
You can't sit at the poker game.
If the poker game, if the stakes is $1,000 and you ain't got 25 cents,
you ain't going to God damn far.
So I would like to see some of our black businessmen
take the chance of putting some money together,
taking one of these small towns,
putting a financial institution on the corner,
okay, what you call it?
But that financial institution will allow you
to open a laundromat.
Everybody got to wash the drawers.
And then I understand that these companies,
these tools that are used to make computers
are done in such a fine fashion that you don't need a PhD
to put the circuits together.
You just need a little training and you can do a decent job.
This kind of financial institution could bring in a company
in a place like Greenwood, Mississippi,
put up a factory, put up a restaurant,
put up a laundromat,
and let that money spin around in that community.
For you know what you start building houses,
I ain't got no money.
If I had some money, I'd do it.
I ain't had no money since they paid me $9.64.
I ain't had no money since then.
It's still ain't got no, but I'm very rich.
But that's what I would like to see coming out of this
because we've done all we could with voter registration.
We've got people hopped up on voter registration
and for what I can see,
and it might sound a little awkward,
but the voter's taking us a little away.
But we've got to get out there,
and we've got to find some way to do it economically.
And then we can control who's in the Congress,
and we can control who's in the Senate.
We can back the boys in there,
and we can then say,
you don't go back no more if you don't do so.
We can't do that because we don't pay for them.
So you were in the federal government,
and you were in the government?
I was there for a little while.
Were you involved in all of the doing the campaign?
No. I was involved in John's first campaign.
And you had a good dream?
Yeah.
Sorry.
And the eight and a good lecture.
I think it was, he ran two times, isn't he?
I think it went running against Julian Bond when we went down.
I think we went the first time.
And he went running against Julian Bond at that time,
because (Marion) Barry and all of us got to modicate together
and went to help him out.
Yeah, I'm not sure.
Now, I don't think it was,
because we wouldn't have went if he was against Julian Bond.
So he was the problem of the first time.
One of the reasons I asked is,
well, I'm jumping ahead a little bit,
but what kind of,
as people left next,
there's been a lot of different kinds of settings,
many ways, things like the continuous,
so there's really as an example,
got involved with drum and steel books for,
a lot of people,
working in Lowndes County.
When the Bobbys, Lowndes County,
because when they were,
he was in that first group,
so when they moved back.
He was, he was, he was, he was.
So what did you do when you came out of tune?
I left, I left SNCC in 60,
65, D765.
Meg Due was here in DC,
and he was director of the United Planning Organization,
center number one,
and he brought me on as his second-in-command in the center.
We ran that center for about a year,
before politically, we got put out,
then after that,
Ed Brown,
Ed Brown.
Ed Brown asked me to come back to Atlanta,
come back to Mississippi,
and work for the Child Development Group of Mississippi.
I went in as the Social Service Director.
I worked there as the Social Service Director
until I got put out of there.
Because I was out of,
well they were in the process of breaking up Child Development Group of Mississippi,
and we were at this meeting with,
with, with one of Stenesis,
Senator John C. Stennis,
and this man just kept,
every time he got ready to say something,
he would, he would preface it with,
can I say something, you boys?
You boys,
and can I tell you boys,
so finally I just,
I asked him,
I asked you a question.
That's why,
is it that every time you get ready to say something to us,
you've got to put some preference on about you boys,
and a damn boy in this room.
Well,
you know what happened after that.
I had lost my job
because you don't talk to Stenesis.
You don't talk to white men in Mississippi that way,
and you don't talk to Senator John C. Stennis that way.
So I got fired again.
So then,
no day
who was married to Peggy Dammond
was part of an organization called,
OSTI,
the OSTI.
There was,
and they were foolish yet to.
No brought me in
because they were dealing with a lot of housing situations,
and they were dealing with a lot of community people,
and involved in,
well, the first project was Detroit,
and we were working with a free Detroit committee,
and Detroit was getting me,
the free Detroit committee was getting me a takeover east side,
and there was this community lady that was blocking them
from doing it,
and they didn't have nobody.
They was going up and they're talking to this lady,
knowing what she was going on.
So that was the first time.
So they were going to be caught up into going into the black community
and reporting back.
Well, after that project,
I went on a,
no-oil had talked to
Kaiser Engineers,
out of Oakland, California.
He had convinced Kaiser Engineers
to work with the Panthers
to acquisition a piece of land
called correct in East Oakland.
They were going to,
from acquisition to building,
planning, acquisition, planning, building, managing all of this,
and it was based on a 40-year plan,
but it didn't have nobody to get to the Panthers.
So no-oil had me to come out,
and of course,
find a way into the Panthers.
Of course, I knew Stokely in,
I knew Stokely was going to be a rap in everybody.
So I started talking to him and they said,
yeah, we might be used this one.
We'll go for this one.
So then he turned me over to the Oakland people.
Well, when I went to the meeting,
I was in Oakland maybe for a couple of weeks or so.
And when I went to the meeting with the Panthers,
I was told, we're not going to deal with you.
One because you've been right around town
and a steel-grade Cadillac.
I said, well, that belongs to Kaiser Cement,
and well, you belong to them.
And I said, would you haven't even heard what I got to offer?
Well, we've heard a little bit of it.
I mean, we don't believe it.
I said, thank you.
I called Noel and I said, hey, you ain't no deal.
You don't need to go through this bullshit.
So in the meantime, I met other people in town.
So I said, well, no, there may be a way out of this.
I've met some community folk.
Maybe we can switch it over and give it to the community folk.
So he said, well, see what you can do.
Timothy L. Jenkins,
who was an advisor to SNCC from the very beginning
and Tim comes out of Yale,
out of National Student Association.
Tim is always, I consider it to be the mouthpiece of SNCC.
So I called him mouthpiece and I said,
hey, man, didn't you introduce me to somebody
that you had a partner somewhere out here?
I'm out here in Oakland, California.
And he said, yeah, I got a man out there by the name of Don Warden.
I said, okay, then I told Tim what I was doing and he said, okay.
Look him up.
So I looked up Don Warden.
I got with Don Warden and then I met him as his love
who was in charge of Social Service Department of Oakland.
I met Mr. Dumbro who was a construction person.
I'm thinking the NAACP's person name was Wes.
I'm not sure about that.
But I formed a community group.
That community group got together with Kaiser.
Got the acquisition of the land.
The senior citizens I was sitting today called West Project Equal.
What was the title of motivation?
I think Lord will tell me that the Kaiser was trying to show
some level of calmness that could happen.
There would be a demonstration that other things could happen.
If housing was a problem, this is one way that you could do it.
And it was a way to show folks who had not been involved in acquisitions
and all of the processes of going about building houses
or getting into the business, they were willing to put up the money.
And this was from big Kaiser aluminum.
This was a subsidiary of Kaiser aluminum sitting there in Oakland.
And I guess this was part of their payback to Oakland.
So I stayed with this company for a little while longer.
They had several construction contracts with different cities
with the model cities kind of stuff.
And each time I would be called in to go talk to the black community
but I couldn't hear what was going on in the white community.
So finally in a meeting I said,
Why do I have to say, why can't I know what's going on in the white folks meeting?
When I only got to go to the black folks meeting and take back what y'all see
happened in the white folks meeting. Why ain't I there to understand what's going on?
Well, you don't need to understand what's going on and you fight.
Yeah, I'm really telling you.
So I'm out on the street again.
I'm married by this time.
I got married late 66, 67 so when I got last at four years.
I'm now having back pains.
I'm having real sharp, sharp back pains.
So I go to the doctor and the doctor tells me I'm having muscle spasms.
And he gives me these little yellow pills and he tells me I have to take,
take them three times a day and after I take them I have to sleep for two hours.
I left the doctor's office and stopped by my favorite drugist.
And back then in the days you could get a whole sharp back full of riefer for $10.
I got me some riefer and I went and got me a fifth of Jack Daniels.
I went home in that same chair that I have sitting in my bedroom now.
I sat in my chair, I sat the pills on my desk.
And I took me a shot of Jack Daniels, I rolled me a joint.
And I sat there and I was trying to figure out how I'm going to sleep for six hours.
Take care of family.
Well, I only had the wife at the time but how am I going to work and sleep six hours?
Well, the first conclusion I came to, that couldn't be done.
So then I started thinking about all of the things that was happening to me at the time.
I had just been out on a consultancy with a buddy and I was working what we called a fish tank.
We were working for this black consultant, this black architect that had a black and white staff
and he went to sensitize the staff.
So I had all of these people in the room that I knew something more than each one of them.
And I had to make them interact in order to get them to understand that this man wanted you to do his work
and to hell with whatever you might think of him and whatever you might think of him.
Just get the contracts done.
Well, afterwards my boys, my guys with Thomas and Reggie did a great job
but you almost blew the act because you smoked three packs of cigarettes in an hour.
So that thought kind of came to me and I lit up another joint.
And I said to myself, maybe cigarettes has got something to do with it.
So I decided the next day I was not going to smoke.
I was going to do everything I did.
Normally every day and I did went through the day.
I came home but wife was blowing smoke because she smoked at the time.
She was blowing smoke on my face and it's, so I talked to a buddy the second day.
And he told me, say you go three days baby, you got it made.
I went fishing the third day.
I ain't smoked since.
I was up to three to nothing.
I just stopped.
I continued to look at the next few days.
I continued to look at them pills and say they ain't over yet.
Then I thought about coffee.
I'd get out to be and put my feet on the floor.
I had to get a cup of coffee.
I could floor I could wash my teeth.
I could get a cup of coffee.
Before I sit down and have a cup of coffee, I had to have a cup of coffee.
I go to, I take the bus.
Before I could get on the bus, I'd have a cup of coffee.
Get off the bus, get on the train, have another cup of coffee.
Before I walk into office, have a cup of coffee, get to the office, have a cup of phone ring, got to have a cup of coffee.
Interview somebody, got to have a cup of coffee.
I'm like this here.
So I said, well.
Coffee is the other one.
So I got rid of coffee and started drinking tea and other kinds of things.
Feeling a little better now.
Now I'm working, but I'm working at something I do not like.
I do not like because I'm not free.
I'm caught up into taking care of family.
My daddy's always, my daddy taught me, my daddy got paid the whole family sat there and he dealt with the money.
He took care of family first.
Then he looked at his hand and said, work shoes.
And then whatever else he had to do, that's the way I felt.
I was in a position that, in that first, OSTI thing.
I didn't even see my paycheck.
I went to the bank.
She had the bank account.
I was one of the expensive accounts.
I had no expense account to do anything I wanted to do.
So I didn't even see money.
Now there's little other little jobs that I'm doing there.
I see the money.
I mean, I'm doing shit that I just do not like.
So the job is a problem.
Well, the job of becoming a problem, the marriage is becoming a problem for all kinds of reasons.
So Bobby Yancy calls me.
Oh, I finally got, well, I hadn't gotten quite got rid of the other job yet, but I'm on my way.
I had rid of this job because this job is part of my misery.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
That was just a quick consultancy.
No, no, no, that was an outside job.
Now I've left Austin.
I'm working for, who am I working for?
I'm a Western University.
I'm doing one of them welfare programs where they got to teach people to read and write or else they get put off a welfare.
I got a school more or less that's running from kindergarten to high school with 35 year old women.
And derelict men and, oh, Lord, have mercy.
And young students who haven't got their life together and crashing out and it's just becoming, you know, I'm just not wanting all of this stuff.
I've been married to a psychiatric social worker too and I'm just used to doing my own hustle.
And one of the things that me and my wife had agreement on is that once she got her masters, then she would handle things as we'd talk about little babies until things get right.
Then you take care of things while I put mine together.
Well, of course, by the time it came round for me, go to school, do this.
Well, I didn't tell you what to do.
Do what you do and I'll do what I'll do and I'll guarantee you everything will work out well.
All of that's happening.
I'm getting this phone call from Bobby Nancy.
Bobby says, got a project in Memphis, Tennessee.
If you're free, come right away.
I had a dog. I made it home.
I walked through the door and there she was, my ex-wife.
And she says, I'm getting another apartment.
I'm leaving.
And what I said to her when we first met was, whenever you get tired of me and you don't hesitate to tell me that you're going to go.
That's the end, that's the end.
So when she said it, I said, no, hold still.
I said, I'm going away for maybe about six weeks.
And when I get back, then we talk or something or other.
And I, over the course of time, I already packed some bags and stuff.
So I went on to this project.
The project was one of the first black caucus dinners in Memphis, Tennessee working for A.L. A.L. Nellum & Associates & Associates.
So we did that project and we came on back and Bobby gave me the option to meet her in DC because she was getting ready to take over a whole project here.
So I came back to Boston and things ain't what they used to be and ain't what they were.
I said, all of that stuff I got packed in the corner in my records and my chair.
And my chair, sitting at the address, I'll send you in.
I left Boston and I've been back here in DC since 81.
What's some of you think so many people have come to DC but maybe they're home?
Well, you can make a living here.
And then with so many of us here, we could get together and help each other.
One of the things that happened to me, even after I, after Bobby took the position with A.L. Nellum & Associates, it wasn't a solid kind of thing to do because he wasn't prepared to do the kinds of operations that was necessary to do the kinds of fundraising that was necessary.
So the project just kind of fell apart and then there I was out there again but because of who I knew around town, I could get other consultancies and little things to survive and then friends would loan me money to pay rent if I couldn't find the rent.
And then I got involved in the charter along with John A. Wilson.
I met and made friends that way and I was involved with a computer company called Afro-American Data Namix,
which was at 14th and Kenyon and it had the only computer on the ground outside of any black institution between here in New York and it was a DEC PDP-11/45.
It recovered its room.
And I was hooked up with a... got it right here.
So we did all kinds of activities such as what our main thing was doing polls and things.
And we did ((Marion) Barry) Barry, very first poll to the numbers and showed where he hooked everybody.
And of course showing him that and working things out after the election we were rewarded with a few contracts and things were going very well.
But back then, his days, electricity was bigger than what we could do.
We couldn't keep that big machine rolling and couldn't bring it enough contracts to keep it rolling so the lights went out.
So after that, I kind of went on unemployment for a few years, which was a good thing.
Then I was asked to come in and work with the youth division at what I worked for Pride before then.
But I was asked to come in and work with the youth division and the Department of Employment Services.
When (Marion) Barry was doing his first... well, it was the time he was doing his second summer youth program.
When we did the 40,000.
The first time was kind of a disaster because they hadn't done the checks and balances.
It was necessary to keep up and match up these kids.
So we matched up kids and kids went to the right places. They got their checks and it was a successful program.
And we did 40,000 one year in the summer and 25,000 in the school year.
I stayed with that program for about two, three years.
Then I went to work as an investigator for the Department of Employment Services in the Department of Employment, unemployment insurance.
And I busted quite a few.
And I sorted quite a few who was arrested.
And at that time the government was changing over from paper to data.
And I got involved in that.
And when I left the government, I was an assistant land administrator.
I was operating at least 100 machines managing and making that 100 machines.
I left the government 20 years to the day.
Only because I had planned to stay longer to help my partner.
Because I promised her I would help her until she got through to got all of the data in and straight.
And she was moving pretty well.
And I promised to stay with her until October.
But that may.
We were very, very busy one day.
I mean, we had elbow, I mean, elbow elbows and work.
And the director came up and said, all right, everybody stop and go down to the war memorial.
So we said, well, why would we have to do that?
I mean, we're busy in that way.
Well, everybody has to be there.
So we went, of course, bosses tell you what to do.
Yes.
So we get down to the memorial and we hear this person.
So this person finishes what he's got to say.
And then he says, I'm like, and as you leave, I'll pick up my records and tapes.
So I turn to my partner and I said, did I hear him, right?
Pick up records and tape.
What is this we're doing?
And then I find out that this guy was somebody they hired to come in as an incentive speaker
to get us to do more work.
And here we were in elbows, ass hole, beeping work.
And they take us, I said, no, this don't make no sense.
So I said, Linda, I see you back up town.
She said, where are you going?
I said, I'm going to person now.
I said, this is kind of bullshit that's coming down and down through this administration.
It just come in.
The new administration just come in.
And they got new people coming in with all of this.
I said, this is the kind of bullshit that's coming in.
I'm going.
I went down, put in my papers.
I was 62 years old.
I was at May.
And I came in in May 61.
And I left May 2001.
I've been out now 15 years doing exactly what I started out to do.
In 1961, it's become a free black person.
And if you notice my emails, I come on my last name, the red comma, FBP.
And I'm dead serious about it.
I am a free black person.
I do every and any thing I want to do.
And that was the purpose of starting out.
That was the goal.
That was my goal to become independent.
I ain't got no money.
But you're independent.
If I'm independent, then I'm rich.
Hey, dude, what you got to do?
I took you long enough to get this one.
So you were...
I know, and I ain't got money.
What were you doing in summer?
64.
Oh, I was in New York.
I was fundraising.
Yeah, I was fundraising.
Well, actually, all through 64, after the...
I see.
I left...
I left and went to work for Senator Joseph D. Tydings,
Senator Joseph D. Tydings, just before the challenge.
I spoke with Ms. Baker about it,
and she says, well, if you feel as though he's going to advance you
in understanding what's going on and everything,
then go ahead and do it.
So I did that.
Then I came back.
Then I was assigned to go and lobby for the MFDP.
I went to California, and I went to Oregon.
I came back, and then I was sent down to Atlantic City
to assist in locating housing and necessary stuff.
Support pieces for the people coming in.
Hooked up with Mary Lovelace O'Neal, who was from NAG,
who was already on the job, trying to deal with this thing,
and Mary being one of those beautiful, beautiful black gals
of our outfit, we ran into one of the biggest gangsters
in Atlantic City by the name of Reggie Edgel,
and all of a sudden, we started getting hotel rooms
and accommodations, and everything else
that was necessary for us to bring out people in.
Then after that, then I was sent to New York
to do special gift fundraising.
I stayed in New York until I went to...
That's when I was doing special gift stuff.
Then from there, I was assigned to go to Philadelphia
office for fundraising.
Then a person by the name of Fred Mealy came to town,
and just... I guess I can say, fucked up.
Everything that we had built, and was going
in an opposite direction, and we lost our gains
that we had in Philly.
Then Jim pulled me out of Philly, and was sending me
to Texas to meet up with a group of people
who wanted to do some fundraising in Texas.
Now I've got to go through Atlanta,
and this is about late 65 now,
and things are in a disarray.
They don't know which way to go and what to do and what to do.
So by the end of the year, MacDoo calls me, and I leave.
So I wasn't... That's what I was doing at 64.
So, things like you were...
Like you did everything, or things like you were the first thing
that we call the call, so that everybody was leaving.
Or like, is that...
Call me that, or call me a Vance man, call me the Pickup man.
I'll make you just allow me.
Yeah, because one time, we weren't getting reports out of the field.
So Jim and I jumped in the car, and of course I don't drive.
And we drove to all of our projects through Mississippi,
through Georgia, Alabama, and everywhere.
I even went up to check on the...
DeGens of Defense in North Carolina.
And while Jim did that, I talked to people and got reports
and put reports back to Julian Bond, even written reports and phone calls and stuff like that.
Is it probably 65?
Is it 65?
This is...
This is 63.
Is it 63?
64.
I don't start the light activity until...
Until after 60, until about 60, late 64.
You tried Jim for them, and so people you had didn't have a chance to meet me.
I would have described the boss.
Well, he was a matter of fact kind of guy.
He was a military thinking kind of person.
He was a person that could tell you the plan,
and almost...
And tell you your spot in the plan.
And if you carried out your spot and bring it back, it fit.
If you deviated from the plan too much, it didn't fit.
But if you followed him, and it did it the way he wanted it to do,
everything would work out.
Were you in the meetings, all of the big meetings about what you did,
what kind of structures should have,
what you did about the floaters and the screen height and the floaters' structures?
Did you get into that?
Tell you the truth.
I was...
I was at a lot of those meetings, but when it came down,
I would only involve myself when it became time to say what we get ready to do.
And when we're at the age we want you to go so and so and so.
I didn't get into those philosophical conversations about Frantz Fanon,
and Frantz Fanon of another thought or Frederick Douglass did.
So I didn't get into all of that.
If we were going to move on a situation, the strategy is this,
if I look out at my moving in,
and I go in to set up stuff, what would you want me to do?
And then I go do it.
That was my position.
And I worked very well with Jim in doing that.
I worked very well with McDoug and doing that.
And that's kind of, I guess, why I...
And Frederick Douglass, or the boss lady was,
with perfect for getting me to do anything she needed me to do.
What about the freedom rights?
What was your thoughts on the freedom rights?
Well, by the time the freedom rights had started, I was in McComb.
And when they were coming back to Jackson returning in 61,
we were making preparations for some of them to come down and work in McComb,
in which we did.
That's how Gwen Green and Travis Britt,
and Ruby Doris Smith Robinson, her boyfriend, Billy, came down,
and there was other freedom riders that came down to work on voter registration.
I got only involved in the freedom rights in Alabama.
One of my assignments was that once the...
Once Montgomery said everybody could ride the buses,
one of my jobs was to go into Montgomery and ride the bus up front.
So, I'm here.
And that's like after you know the...
I contact people coming out the bus.
Yeah, well, that's kind of where it was.
And that's why I was a little skeptical
when I got to...
When I got when I was involved in this New York thing coming out of New York
and Bill Hanson is announcing and going in the Cambridge,
you had to go around into a dark corner where the bus stop is.
And who knows who would have met us up in there?
I mean, there was a certain amount of secrecy about this yet.
I mean, did you did?
You didn't just go frequently and now Bill is a professor in Nigeria or Lagos or somewhere.
And I don't know how he felt, but at the 50th,
he was the only one walking around in the Grand Bougain.
I mean...
So, I don't know.
So, Hanson, I met Archim,
I was providing you with two of my business channels.
Yeah?
Oh, it worked.
It was a charm.
He was...
He too was somebody that you would listen to and you noted it had a knowledge of organization.
And he was...
He was somebody you could work with.
And he was somebody you know you could walk, you could walk the line with.
If you were in the struggle with him, you would air with him and he was with you.
You weren't afraid to be out there.
He was a good man.
You ever in Albany?
Yes, I was in Albany.
One of the things about Albany is that the girls had gotten locked up.
And Jim and I had went out to see about him.
And we went on our way back and Jim had to go to the bathroom.
So, Jim made this stop.
And he went into this restaurant and went into this kind of film station.
And he came back out in a hurry holding his self and he got back in the car.
And I said, why are you holding this?
I was in the go to the bathroom.
He says, no.
I said, he says, I'll hold it till I get down the road.
That's what's wrong.
He says, there was a guy in there with a gun.
And I didn't think this was the proper opportunity to give up my life for the revolution just to take a piss.
So, I decided to get back in the car and let it out down the road.
So, that was just one little thing.
But then, when I was one of my jobs at the height of what I was in there before a king came in.
And I was helping Charles Sherrod to do some stuff.
Then I was brought back in when all of King's men came in.
And my job, because some of those guys knew me like YT and Andy and everybody.
I could kind of slide around.
So, my job was to hang around Dr. Anderson's house.
They had a Dr. Anderson in Albany where they stayed.
And just listen.
I was just next by.
Next day, it's the LC.
But now, one night, I was sitting there and YT came to me and said, come on, take a ride with me.
So, we got in the car.
We drove to the jail.
YTC, he had taken this train into dock.
And they said, what?
He said, take this train into dock.
And they had made the deal with the chief of police.
There was no food that would come in to dock.
Not less, it came from the movement people.
So, I said, I'm going to take this in.
So, I said, I kind of say, oh, you're paying me back.
And then, and him and Martin and Abernathy was in their cell.
And they both had on a silk pajamas.
And they were both laughing and talking.
And I gave each one of them their trays.
And Martin sat down and said, thank you.
And immediately started eating old poke chops.
I had nicknamed for Rev. Ralph Abernathy.
Old poke chops looked at me and said, boy, they forgot to chuckle an ice cream.
I said, yeah, but I ain't bringing it back to you.
As I proceeded to say, Jella.
So, I went back out of white, not late after.
We went on back to the house and sat around and looked at some more and listened to some more and whatever.
And then, you know, did what I had to do and follow Charles Sherrod orders.
And went up in Baker, in Turral, and did voter registration and stuff like that.
But I was only there for a very short period of time.
In the early periods.
And doing the big one is when I was really there.
I spent time there.
What about some?
Did you go back to time?
No, no, no.
I never went back to Selma until, until, until, until, 19.
When did Bob Moses take me down?
Yeah.
It was, it's just been maybe about eight and nine years ago.
When they started to do believe stuff.
He, he took me down in there.
And I was really surprised to see all of the turkey wings and the festivities and everything.
And he says, yeah, I just wanted to show you what's going on from your work.
And then he took me to the folks that was involved in the Jubilee and everything.
And he introduced me as the first snicker that landed in Selma.
And of course, folks is, oh, you know, oh yeah, okay.
And that was it.
But that was about it.
So then...
Right.
And so then I would go down every year because Bob Moses would do his thing.
And the Jubilee would do his thing.
Bob Moses had an organization called the Trail.
And the Trail was made up of people that was up at the, at the center of things in Lowndes County.
That's where the Tent City was on 80.
Right there where they put that incentive center there.
And they're still trying to get Bob Moses's information.
And Bob Moses's family's still ain't going to put it in there because he didn't want them to have it.
Was that Tent City?
Was that from the building?
The basement lounge?
That was from the march.
And you didn't have a go in the lounge?
Did you ever go to the park lounge or the dining room?
No, no, no, no.
I hooked up with Bob Moses later on and about doing some other kinds of stuff.
But we were always in touch.
You can have them all the time, right?
Yeah.
More house and all of that.
And that brother's got him and Joanne.
Man's came out of...
In Albany?
Because Joanne is from Albany.
Yeah, that's how he met.
Right, right, right.
You remember that picture, right?
I love being...
She became a friend, she became a close mother kind of thing.
I guess I got close to her because of the relationship of my mother and her.
And when I was changing over from the tidings campaign going back in the field for the
Doudalabian for the MFTP, Miss Hamer was in DC
So I got Miss Hamer, Miss Baker, they come over and my mom was fixed lunch for them
and my mom's in Miss Baker had a real old girl get together kind of thing.
When I got married the night before I got married Ella and Joanne Grant took me out and got me drunk.
Trying to make sure that I am doing what I intend to do.
And then I of course got married at Harry Belafonte's house.
And of course my mother was there and of course Ella and my mother.
Of course knowing each other was like my support pieces.
Ella was Mama.
When I ran into...
Like when I was in...
Before I left Cambridge in between things things got kind of tough.
And I was having trouble at home with my mom's and I was actually...
I was actually having trouble in Cambridge and I needed some time out.
So Ella suggested that I go talk to Joe Baker who was on the Medical Committee for Human Rights and she was a psychiatrist.
So Miss Baker suggested that I go talk to her.
And when I went to talk to Joe of course she says, you ain't crazy.
You just mixed up a lot of stuff that you can't figure out right now.
So what we're going to do is we're going to send you to not mount Eagle.
Peekskill. Peekskill in New York for about a week.
And what you're going to do up there is just rest, read, do everything you know.
And then at the end of the week there's a fundraiser.
The Paul Robeson fundraiser when Paul Robeson is the history of when Paul Robeson spoke in Peekskill.
And John Hammond Jr. is going to be on the program and everything.
And you're going to just take yourself a little rest.
So I went to Peekskill.
Had lots of fun.
And spoke on what I knew about Paul, but Paul Robeson.
And then got a surprise of being taken to Sam and Helen Roverson's house.
Who Sam, Sam Roverson was the doctor that went to Russia to bring back Paul Robeson.
And while I'm sitting there in Katonah, New York outside resting my feces in the good sun,
this big black man comes out and sits next to me with this deep voice.
And we introduce ourselves in damn for any Paul Robeson.
So then Doc comes out and they had such a house that they had a sauna.
And you walk to the sauna and then you walk down these stairs and you get under this natural stream.
So there's here's us men in this sauna, buck naked, running out, running down under this Jesus,
ice cold mountain water and just talking and I am with Paul Robeson.
Well, I can't thank Ella enough for taking me out of this situation.
So I go back into Cambridge and I'm revitalized now and I've gotten all my stuff together as to what I'm doing.
So I'm talking to Ruby about what's going on and what I'm feeling and what's happening.
So Ruby's saying, well that's when we began the process of my moving out because one of the other things that Gloria did was
Gloria tried to petition Atlanta for me to stay and it was really time for me to go.
And so that became a bone of contention.
Did you feel like they could do it in your own house?
Yeah.
But I knew that they were on and on.
Well, I got rid of all of the surrounding people like like,
as I said, the NAACP and all of the big organizations was coming in once we got things going when the students were coming in.
So now the board is taking care of and taking care of the situation.
But there was this other group coming in.
With Carol Rogoff, this reporter was very hot on Carol
So I got Carol to get this reporter to take me for a ride.
And we had a little conversation about silk suits and denim and guys who were denim.
And they organized us who worked in denim closer to the people, local people.
And the ones that's in these shiny silk suits are coming in making collections.
Well, the story got out the next day.
And of course, the local folks wanted to know where such a story came from.
But they all linked it back to the NAACP and they chased them out of town.
So the local board then began the run-in business.
And they had nobody else outside of SNCC who was not making any turf kind of...
Right, right, right, right.
You were building the organization.
But we were making good on what SNCC was doing in Cambridge.
And Cambridge was doing okay.
So it wasn't necessary for us to control as the big organization.
The idea was you make these things and then you control them and then you last for hundreds and hundreds of years.
That's the end of the day?
Well, yeah.
And the NAACP has come a long way and done a damn good fight and still doing a good fight.
But their fight isn't the only fight.
They take the fight to the point of the courts.
But there's always the courts are part of the system which has a certain amount of dictation.
But just like what's happening today, you got to push the envelope.
I grew up in Baltimore.
All of that stuff that happened last week from Freddie Gray just didn't happen.
People have been out of work.
People have been taken away from opportunities.
I got a cousin that lives in Pikesville MD.
You have to, when you go in out to her house, you have to come up righteous to up Pikesville MD.
And if you get to Pikesville MD and Pikesville MD, or one side to street is the Pikesville MD.
Multimillion dollar operation on this side of the street is junkies.
Land in the street.
It does not make any sense.
This side of the street is the Jewish community clean.
This side of the street is junkies.
Multimillion dollar operation sitting here.
Downtown Baltimore.
You got to walk.
You got all of that money coming in and people coming in.
And by you got the Pikesville MD gambling and going on and you come three four blocks.
Nothing.
You got people out of work.
You got black people that will walk down to the to the to the wall, going to Philips and will look different.
Look at you differently.
And ain't nothing changed in Baltimore until something comes about in all of these cities.
If they chase that dude out of Chicago, what's going to take his place?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, what's going to take his place?
It looked like they may or may not have fixed this guy in Baltimore.
But the police are part of the problem.
The police are probably the police are part of the power.
And the power is which controls.
That's what's controlling all of these wars and everything else.
They said on this television this morning that they're going to take away people's oil
in order to stop them from killing people.
Well, you take away somebody else's income.
What are they supposed to do? What fight you?
So you just same thing in Baltimore.
The same thing in Chicago, the same thing in Ferguson.
They got to do it.
And we, we can play a role.
And it seems to me to be very simple.
There's more rich black folks today than there was in 1920.
There seems to me that there ought to be enough, they have guts enough
to put the money together and come to the poker table and play the game.
We can do laundry bats.
We can do computer and we can get together with one of them companies
that do the computer tools.
We can teach people to get jobs, decent jobs to make a living.
And that's where I think we ought to go.
I think that's the direction.
I think that's the direction because voter registration is leading us to people
who elected on the hill that I don't see any difference in them having.
I don't know exactly how Congress works, but they work from rules.
So when you become a part of the rule, then you become a part of the problem.
So you can't do this because this rule goes over here.
You can't do this because this rule's over here.
Just because I'm no different than anybody else.
When they say you're going to have a black president, I consider I start thinking
that my world is going to become different.
My world is going to become different.
I did not expect no black president, the whole no no no no no no no.
Be a conference after another black man has been stopped in his doorway
and locked up for going in his own house and he's got to sit down and pick up an appeasement.
No no no no no.
There's something wrong.
That's not from position.
We're not in power.
And these boys that sit up on the hill, God bless them.
But they ain't doing no different than the boys did in construction.
Except too many of them may have spitting tobacco on the side.
But I don't know about, I know that voter registration leads to new leadership.
And new leadership leads to change in a sense.
Ferguson now has a chance of changing because now more black people are involved in the process.
What do you think of Smith's move towards black power?
As exactly what I'm talking about now.
The move towards black power was not to use guns.
Was not to use guns.
They threw the media through the whole thing off when they could latch on to Bobby Seale and the rest of them with a gun plane.
I mean we were talking about the same thing that I'm talking about now.
Opportunities to make money in order to create money for people to make money to buy houses.
To be able to control schools, to be able to get recreation centers, to do things for kids, to make kids grow, and do things in our community that we know that we want to have our own religions and do what we want to do without being dominated by it.
We were not talking about guns.
Because we know we can't win with guns. The Indians didn't win with guns.
And nobody else had won with guns in this.
When I think when Japan was trying to make some kind of deal that dropped a bomb on them over there and locked up everybody over here.
You can't deal with these people that way.
So if we had our own, if we had our base functioning in such a sense that they knew that we would come after them, the black politicians as well as the white ones, with a power base coming from a power base.
Some of these entrepreneurs that have made money. Some of these black folks that live in the water gate. Some of these ones that don't have to worry about it coming back on them that they can do things without it coming back on.
Put that money together.
And let's go out and fight.
Did you have an ordinary to go back in Mississippi after you left my home?
Yeah, I was with the child of the vote in Mississippi.
So do you have anything else to think about?
Yeah.
I can't help me out there.
I can't ask you anything else.
All right.
I can't unhide you with this.
What do you want people to know about the movement?
That we were lucky enough to have somebody like Ella Baker to present us with a very, very simple plan as taking people from where they are and bringing them up.
Those that are already on top don't necessarily need to push, but they need to support those from the bottom.
And those from the bottom would understand what the opportunities are for them and given the opportunity to look at that and examine that, then more people would move on their own and make decisions.
Based on their need, which would be, I think, I think that the majority of folks would begin to see that we all need the same thing.
And it would be easier to come together.
So I think that we left folks with us.
Something that I think that wasn't dealt with in any other movement.
We dealt with the thing that let folks know that they are the leaders.
But there's no one leader.
If you get up and you want to do something, somebody's going to follow you.
But you got to go and do what you want.
You got to know that you want to do something.
And you become a leader then.
And if enough people do that, then we have a movement.
We don't need another Martin Luther King.
And that was one of the things that we tried and still trying to get away from.
Even that movie that Oprah did.
I mean, she used a lot of money to tell a story that could have been told a totally different way and give up a lot of information that it would have been true instead of some factual, unfactual situation.
And compared that to the one that Robinson did called Freedom Song, where he depicted us going into Mississippi,
registering people to vote, getting the people involved as opposed to having Jim and John sitting in front of a conference with Jose reprimanding Jim Forman.
That has never happened.
Jim was not that kind of person.
Jim was as old as Martin.
Jim was as more of a leader than Martin.
And Jim had his own organization and was aware of the fact of having his own organization and having the strength of backing of his own people to say any damn thing he needed to say.
And at that point, we were already been chased out of Selma.
And he's already chased out of, I'm not Selma, but chased out of Southwest Georgia with them blastering in and not leaving anything.
Right.
Now what I'm talking about the movie, I'm talking about Oprah, right.
And then Oprah in a car, and then John in a car with Martin driving and Martin talking, that's bullshit.
Martin ain't drove no damn way.
And we didn't put John Lewis out.
It was John Lewis's choice to leave.
Always believed that he wanted to be an SCLC person anyway because he was brought up under that preacher, Jim Lawson,
loved that neighbor, Gandhi, whatever that stuff was.
I mean,
Were you at the meeting where I felt he was elected?
No, no, I wouldn't need either.
I wouldn't need either.
But Oprah could have used her money to do a different, if she wanted to do anything she should have shown the relationship that went on.
Because they were scared to death in Selma.
And they were scared to death in Albany, Georgia.
And each place they were telling us, don't do this. You all won't get killed.
The same thing that adult advisors was telling us everywhere, just stop.
So...
Yeah, it's not a very good depiction of the movie.
No, no, no.
Right. And they...
For some reason they want to...
They want to either rewrite the history or write us out.
And that's one of the things I think the value of the SNCC Legacy Project is.
Because it's coming back in a way that allows us to say and do what we know to do, which is organized.
I just got to email asking what to do, when to do, raising money and everything.
And I responded, I'm available.
Except for a couple of things.
I got to take piano lessons and recognize them dates.
And I'm trying to get some new needs.
So those are the only things.
Otherwise, I'm available to move.
If you want me to go down into Selma and go down into Ferguson to talk to some of them, I'll go.
And whatever you need me to do, if you don't conflict with my obligations, I'm free to go.
I still play the same role, if you need me.
If you need me, if you don't need me, leave me alone and I go fishing.
Which is something I love to do.
Any final thoughts?
Any minute?
I guess it's my dream to see a group of black folks come together in a financial kind of situation that's honest enough and got enough guts to not to be worried about consequences, but to be worried about a program and what's moving ahead and use our resources for what we know we can use them for.
And it's simple kinds of things that we can get involved in and help our community to grow.
Such as if we had a bank on the corner that could loan, that could loan, Miss Johnson, $25 to open up a laundromat,
loan, build Henry, $25 to open up a pool hall and that money comes back as some recreation.
Somebody else may want a restaurant.
Maybe we can talk one of these companies, one of these high tech companies are coming into a small town like Greenwood.
And Red Brown had a manufacturing company going on called Mace.
Where they made denim.
Why can't we find outlets and then let that money roll around in the community before it goes on.
Then it can go out on the stock exchange.
Henry G. Parks Jr, who I mentioned earlier on, they didn't find out that he owned Parks Sausage Co.
You know what Parks Sausage Co is? Parks Sausage Co is a sausage that's been out for years.
And it had a commercial called Bob Moses Mopalk sausage.
But it was a black, it was known as a black home business.
But everybody thought it was owned by Henry G. Parks Jr.
But it was actually owned by Henry G. Parks Jr.
And until it went on the stock exchange, nobody knew that it was owned by Henry G. Parks Jr.
But Henry G. Parks Jr was pushing money around in the community from a policy book.
Now if one man can have all of this business, he had businesses from Pikesville MD from Pikesville MD down to Pikesville MD.
He owned a Royal Theatre, which was all a part of the Chitlin' Circuit.
I'm saying if one man can take his finances, he sent his wife to the Victorine Q. Adams.
If one black man can put this kind of money together and do these kinds of things,
just think of maybe seven or eight putting in some money and going to work.
And when the clan walk up and say, you can't do this, fuck you.
We got enough to do it.
And I understand.
And somebody told me, says, well, Reg, once you build this kind of thing,
the bigger people will come in and buy it.
I said, well, then that makes it even better.
Because if we got something small here and the bigger people want to buy,
that means that more economics is coming down in here.
And that's where we want to see.
It want to see it grow.
So we don't want to see it to stop.
So if that can happen, I love to see that happen.
Somebody could say, you can talk to somebody.
You can say it works there.
That's it every day.
Well, I can't thank you enough for bringing to the Congress to have the chance to do these things.
Well, it all has something to do with me too.
USA Today just did a thing with me and I suppose we'll be coming out soon.
I was looking for that report and didn't find it.
And there's other kinds of questions that's coming up about me.
So and then,
legacy is trying to pull stuff together for us to do things.
So I figured it.
Right.
And for whatever reasons,
you know my policy of somebody coming up and asking me for an interview.
But if it's done in the context of what the legacy is doing,
then and you go to Charlie and Charlie proves it and everything.
That's cool with me, but still if anybody comes to me,
you know the policy.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.